what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch chucky episode two today hey
can you hit that like button
that helps us out in the algorithm
subscribe click the notification bell to
get notified when our next reaction for
chucky is up we're trying to play catch
up here john why don't you finish the
rest guys if you like this and you want
to see more come on over to our patreon
we got full length watch alongs and
reaction highlights included for many
shows chucky included but also all these
other shows you're seeing thumbnails for
and last but not least big thanks to
eric at nerd chronic for jumping in
helping us knock these out love you
buddy you're a big life saver let's jump
into the the the next episode
oh so you think you're better than me i
don't know never i would never say that
yeah
i just set myself up for all the
comments that tell me that you're better
than then my intros are just the best
intros
[Music]
oh
ah
oh oh that made me
ah
kiddo
why would you do that
lack of cheese something was always off
about that boy
remind me what's your protein intake
this week
uh 50 grams a day
oh
let's bump that up to 75. just have a
cliff bar before lunch okay
okay
he has equally hard problems that's jake
that's right all this stuff he's gotta
eat
hey jake
yeah
for lunch for your
gofundme have a good day
it's gonna take more than that
should have given him more money yep you
didn't miss much miss have trouble pop
quiz and then junior's pissed about what
you said about me and lex you mean what
chuck he said right that [ __ ] was
hilarious look jake
weird
both
i'm having a party tonight and i think
it'd be really good for you if you came
halloween party costumes coronas and
candy and we're not talking to m m's
his parents are in london for the
weekend so um i don't have a costume
it's all right just ring chucky
i feel like we're watching a tommy
wiseau movie i know
what happened there hi
hi
jake
i've been thinking about it
you have what we've been going through
you know my dad died when i was nine
yeah i remember you going to oliver's
party tonight
i think so yeah
awesome bringing chucky oh no why not
you two really killed the other night
at the talent show
[Laughter]
no don't kill the mate
interesting use of sound design in this
show
you shouldn't go through a kid's journal
[Music]
[Music]
make her your personal stylist chuck
not suspicious at all about the blood
huh mean she's collecting
half the drawer
oh geez
that you that's not the way you put
those in there
cool shots
no
thank you
what are you doing
call 9-1-1
look over there
who are we going to hire
who's going to want to be our maid now
it's just i know it's a cliche but annie
really was a part of this family what
was her home address oh here oh this is
embarrassing um
family
anybody we should notify she has a
brother
i think he lives in uh
baltimore really was family
really got to know her yeah
this is the second freak accident in
this town in less than a week
and your nephew is at a ringside seat
for both
he was at school yeah so please let me
handle this okay handle what
yes what exactly are you saying you
could tell how long she's been dead for
her but what am i yeah you would think
annie was insane she welcomed her with
open arms like she did everyone
she might have had a brother
gotta say writing's not your forte you
should just call it devin devin devin
shut up
i have a queer kid
you have a kid
gender fluid
glennar glenda
i'm not a monster jake
no you are you killed annie we only kill
people who have it coming and let me
remind you
that i could have killed anybody in this
house during the last week at any time
including you
you of all people should know some
people deserve to die
he's still so adorable sometimes you
know you still want a good guy doll
despite all this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
split diopters man
what the hell are you doing
uh
just gonna ask you the same thing wait
don't look at this
let's not stay away from her
i didn't do that
no
what are you gonna do
[Laughter]
sounded like a punch sound effect
happened
carolyn would you maybe like to meet
chucky sometime i bet your sister could
make that happen
what oh god egg
that thing belongs to jake wheeler and
i'm sorry but did you not hear him
talking [ __ ] about me at the talent show
and wait you should be flattered the
whole thing was all about you
it's called bullying he's a bully
who's a bully chucky no
that is uncanny yeah
lexi your sister has a gift
and she's better at this than you've
ever been at anything in your entire
life
no i'm sorry just can't take your
attitude anymore jeff did jake ever say
anything about his father
about his father hurting him
like
maybe because he's gay
how would i know
i don't
i'm just doing my job
as a mom
or a cop
a mom a bit of both i guess a mop
damn you said this [ __ ] so fast i know
that's the way type message yeah
damn
all these kids at this public school is
just freaking wealthy what the hell it's
the wealthiest part of the nation you
look great
are those my medals yeah
are you going as me
wow jake
you look incredible
oh
no
actually um
i changed my mind
i don't think i'm up for a party tonight
okay
can i show you some of my medals
[ __ ]
where is he
what are you talking about
chucky
he's gone
oh [ __ ] he's cape fear in the car
a party the haydens have a big halloween
party every year well thanks baby
here's your treat
thank you
oh my god oh she was a nice lady
chucky you seen chucky dude you lost
your doll
jake
five bro
uh
seven minutes in half
jake we might as well take advantage
yeah
we can't get out now
you're good at this junkie
you too caroline killings good clean fun
for the whole family
you could kill the housekeeper oh god
you can even kill your sister
oh mommy says real killing is bad
yeah well mommy's full of [ __ ]
where's lexi
probably kissing junior somewhere
well at least she's gonna die doing what
she loves
i haven't done anything yet no duh i
noticed
just forget it oh god
already
oh
what you want me to do well you're
supposed to know what to do
the mattress moved
[Laughter]
wow
great direction
what
oh
no
that is so twisted yeah i i can't let
her get away with this you don't have to
do that oh don't say that no don't don't
don't say those words
what it's like to get hurt
don't please don't stop god damn it
oh
i'm sorry i i didn't get that it was
this horrible redheaded child
take her to the hospital
and denim overalls
had something
stitched on them good gay
good good guy
she had to call the cops cops had to
come and she replied this whole time
oh jeez
no
jake wait
oh
okay it's good that you didn't die
yeah i mean it would be over for tv yeah
like i said before jake
some people just deserve to die
make the right choice jake
kill the [ __ ] before she kills you
i don't know if i can do that
man the [ __ ] up i'm the only real friend
you got in the whole world devin
don't forget devin devin take the knife
jake
you know you want to don't put your
prints on that thing
congrats kid
you're going to the super bowl
oh
good use of reflection
jesus
yeah
i want them to end things are escalating
fast this is not what you call a slow
burn and
that is the way you do a chucky show
you keep the momentum going you do
enough teasing to you know spread things
out but yeah
i think it's great how they've managed
to make the story of jake and his
surrounding
characters be the real investment here
because
you could feel like chucky serves as
this
insidious
like
secondary character who's slowly coming
to the forefront you know like that if
anything that's the one slow burn effect
is chucky's coming slowly to the
forefront here yeah as he is like
i love how he's doing uh not just
directly murdering and then him and then
jake being accused like that look that's
probably going to become a prevalent
part of this show
but like how he's talking with a little
girl influencing the mind of her now
influencing jake because [ __ ]
chucky's got a point man i never was
addicted to him except for devin yeah
but you know like the fact that everyone
was just laughing about what she was
doing
yeah
bitch's name oh
goodness i hate her i hate her i i even
if i met her in real life the actress i
would be that person yeah i would be
that guy on the internet who would treat
her as if she's really that person in
real life
just assume you know you're too good at
playing that person then you must be
that person yeah i hate you yeah and you
should be ashamed of what you did to
that fictional character
did you consent to be in a show like
this
i mean this one brought more of the like
they the other one had dramatic weight
um but it was still kind of finding its
stride to let the dramatic moments hit i
thought there was some real effective
moments here that were genuinely tense
um some parts that were a little scary
and then yeah that part at the dance
when she was dancing like making fun of
jake's dad that was like really
messed up yeah that was like sadistic as
like really
you could just feel it within how much
of the line is being crossed right there
and how cruel it is yeah and the
violence
oh apple razor blade it's simple but
effective man it's like a simple blood
gag but it makes your skin crawl and i
felt so bad for that lady i find it
interesting how um
uh mancini has
delved into the chucky world with this
layer of trauma
and how the the cycle repeats itself
because you're seeing that now they're
doing that with the actual chucky
character yeah of hey when he was a boy
he did this biting into an apple razor
blade thing but he kind of enjoyed it so
he's not really like traumatized
something was always off and i think
it's interesting that they did that
halloween
you know visual
mirroring because you know it's like
michael myers there's that element where
it wasn't boring
it seems like charles lee ray has a bit
of that as well
yeah except they're doing it without the
rob zombie hick stuff exactly it's just
a you know a perfectly nice respectable
home he's just a dude i got a loving
mother and i'm a sick kid that's it yep
and yeah
like some of the some of the more campy
elephants it will pull me out when i'm
like but come on my logical brain wants
to fight against it
like the lady with the apple
of
why is because she would have to have
bit the apple
yeah started bleeding
and then have called the cops
and she's still gushing blood i'm like
why is there not an ambulance you're
here to help her out
or he'll at least drive to the hospital
if you can why is the detective looking
a tad impatient with
her could you speak more clearly please
like no she can't
and i'm really endeared to the
sympathetic relationship and the bond
that's forming with devin and jake too i
find that very heartfelt yeah it feels
very sincere like whenever you know
devin shows up like jake because every
scene jake's
and then devin shows up
i mean hey
hey what's up what's up bro what's up
dude
you want to go give me some chicks bro
what's going on bro you wanna
touch ourselves like some of the female
stuff yeah
seven minutes hit you you're a dude get
away from me
right
now i'm rooting for them i'm really
hoping devin doesn't die absolutely they
got me there i'm really concerned devin
will die i'm concerned chucky will find
evan a threat
i think he will by the end of it
although they'll be battling for both
the soul and the heart of jake they
they've got me there everyone else can
die but
yeah yeah i mean i keep rooting for uh
his aunt and uncle to maybe step it up
and become okay not that i think they
won't die but you know at least to make
it like oh i actually didn't want them
to die by the end of this they're
portrayed pretty realistic yeah and i
mean they clearly don't know how to
reach them but they're among the
characters who are a little more you
know outside of that box of just oh you
guys are all terrible and i i i'm very
curious to see if junior actually does
come around or if it's gonna be that
thing where he always
he takes more and more notes of the
cruelty but by the time he decides to do
something about it it'll probably be too
late that junior kicker
i mean yeah thus far he's been pretty
pretty shitty crosstalk awful kid he's
just awful
yeah
no sympathy for jake's plight and
whatsoever no no he doesn't even seem to
care about his uncle your family yeah
that's your family yeah and he's being
like severely bullied yeah
i mean why your girlfriend
yeah
and i mean i like that they had that
thread they've at least established that
thread because in the previous episode
they're like oh you know junior's a good
kid it's it's just lexie that's the bad
influence on him
and it seems like he is i mean pretty
down with a lot of these things i mean
again i did appreciate that
towards the end there he is even like
is messed up
but uh yeah
i don't know i'm curious to see how long
he makes it he treats him like crap at
home yeah he's an awful guy yeah
but but even at the at-home stuff played
in a way where i was like okay teenagers
you know like teenagers who are clearly
standoffish with each other already and
now have only more reasons to be
this was real life
i i i'd share that point of view
put in a show in a show yeah you could
cut that kid
it's just a matter of when and the other
thing is is when is lexi's sister gonna
go full chucky because i feel i mean
like that's that is an element of of you
know the previous films is yeah like
chucky does his thing kind of warms his
way into somebody's graces and then you
know ultimately gets to frame them and
i'm curious too about like don mancini
said he kind of wanted for the show for
chucky to be
the ultimate bully sort of who always is
kind of manipulating the cat slider yeah
to make you think that he's your buddy
when actually he's the one kind of
the the core of terribleness around you
yes
uh yeah he's trying to murder the maid
and lied to jake yeah yeah yeah he's a
horrible he's a horrible guy absolutely
and and so it's a compelling little like
fight for yeah the soul of jake because
i can see like exactly why chucky would
appeal to certain of his feelings it
does bother me a little bit
if there's one thing though i gotta say
it does bother me a tiny bit how jake
doesn't even make an attempt
to set up a phone to recapture chucky oh
yeah because i feel like he could
yeah there's ways that's what kind of
insurance policy
you press proof this doll's moving and
talking and stuff yeah exactly yeah
that way he could say like it's not me
it's the dog remember the murder dolls
there's a real weird thing happening
here with this doll yeah pocket phone or
something like that you know
because uh yeah yeah there's got to be a
way to get him on camera there's got to
be a way i mean even if he like buddies
up with devon and it's like
i know like chucky doesn't fall asleep
or something but
it just does the toy story
do the toy story
you're my favorite deputy
yeah they're
yeah i could just imagine i feel like
there's because the kid also because the
kid's creative yeah jake is a very
creative kid and uh as clearly
demonstrated by his sculpting abilities
that i feel like he would figure out
ways to trap them into a hidden camera
thing yeah yeah
i mean the only thing i guess i would
wonder is is he really going to be able
to outsmart chucky in that department
because you know chucky always sees and
knows more than you give him credit for
well he's in one room chucky
so one way you could do it
is find a place to set up the phone yeah
because where chuck he has to be in the
room and the only way he can get out of
the room is by going through that one
door
so when he goes out the door you got
your footage
okay
he encounters him
you know yeah no one's home so we got we
got it next episode
buying up all the gopros in town
so wiring the house taping your phone or
something yeah
yeah that would be there's ways to there
are ways to do it without making
yourself conspicuous
yeah because everyone's got phones yeah
yeah yeah they do and i mean chucky
clearly knows how to use the internet
but uh
no he does
but yeah yeah yeah you could i feel like
you could easily pocket phone you know
you just start recording drop it in your
pocket make sure the camera's sticking
out you know
you move for just a few seconds
talking you know
sir some people might say it's fake
no that's the problem though is he's
gonna do it in the next episode show it
to somebody and they're gonna be like
wow you used after effects so well to
make this this is great that's true you
know it's halloween people are like whoa
that punch uh you're trying to freak me
out the kid who doesn't have a costume
and is obviously bullied all the time
looks like he applied real makeup to
himself and i'm not gonna question at
all if he was actually punched nope no
it's just shockingly real makeup by the
artistic kid in school
what's else to to notice about that
but this is still like a really
enjoyable episode it provided it amped
up the fear it happened amped up the
suspense i feel like they are
essentially doing a chucky movie but in
a long form format which i find
better because of the fact that
you get time to actually get invested in
the storyline outside of chucky
it's great stuff and uh i i find i
really like the the style of this show a
lot as you keep talking about this the
um
the sleep apnea shot you know with the
deviation
you know split diameters split die after
shots are great and it's like an older
thing that's the right way to say it
yeah they believe it's spectrum diameter
spectrum spectrum deviance the dvds
learn your
learn your director of camera operating
terminology the spaghetti de laurentiis
was amazing in this episode
yeah but also the sound design of when
to amplify certain moments to have like
the whip sound effect or the wish sound
effects on certain things that comes up
a lot of times normal but then when
you're cutting to a threatening
perspective it's
yeah they they know when to go into that
and the violence was gross in this one
and it's also nice to see a horror thing
where it's actually halloween and it
felt like halloween yeah because it
doesn't like you know a lot a lot of
things don't do that in the horror
true but it's nice to have even though
we're watching this after halloween just
that vibe in the room it felt more like
halloween than anything else we watched
and felt more like halloween than
halloween yeah no dude
yeah so better late than never right
all right well guys thanks so much for
being here make sure to subscribe hit
that like button
hey let's do a
eric horstmann
dude if anybody deserves to star in a
chucky movie it would be you because you
would be the first protagonist who would
have no debate just get fully on board
with chucky from the get-go you'd
basically be his sidekick and at that
point you and chucky would just go
around taking care of all the people who
annoy you the most in this world i hope
that doesn't include us i feel like she
would make chucky his lover too
absolutely i mean chucky and i mean i
know chucky loves tiffany and all that
stuff but you know that chucky is an
open fluid individual as well can you
imagine eric the doll and jennifer tilly
jennifer tilly and doll form make it a
four-way all of them together that's the
chucky don't even put any kills just
make it like a porno
that's do make a chucky porno and send
it to me
that's what i want eric
i think uh
i think jennifer tilly ruins it no no i
you know what you're right she does ruin
it how about
let's get uh just more chucky dolls
let's get chucky's kid in there too
let's get glenn glenda in there and
there you go no no girls allowed
now let's bring jennifer tilly back
let's get jennifer tilly back in there
because what could be sexier than an
eric and a jennifer tilly and you know
just a pile of chuckies on top
why stop there throw freddy in throw
ghost face in michael's in no take
michael out he's mad freddy
just chucky
you guys know when to cut the camera
it doesn't just cut automatically
[Music]